nous ne voulons rien négocier c'est par
ces mots que le président brésilien a
harangué la foule venue réclamer devant
le qg de l'armée
la fin du confinement et une
intervention militaire pour fermer le
parlement et la cour suprême le juge de
la cour suprême fédérale a condamné ces
revendications
selon lui elle porte atteinte à l'état
de droit démocratique du brésil
il a aussi demandé une enquête sur
d'éventuels forme de financement d'actes
anti démocratique
ce lundi jacques bolson araud a répété
qu'il souhaitait que le confinement
prenne fin j'espère que c'est la
dernière semaine de quarantaine pour en
finir de cette façon de combattre le
virus chacun chez soi il est impossible
que les gens restent chez eux avec un
frigo vide
cette déclaration intervient quatre
jours après le limogeage du ministre de
la santé
luis enrique yeves en d'état favorable
confinement et à la distanciation
sociale cette orthopédiste de profession
a irrité le pouvoir en affirmant sur la
chaîne tv globo que les brésiliens ne
savent plus s'ils doivent écouter le
ministre ou le président mais le
successeur de monde et à l'oncologue
nelson tech ne semble pas non plus
disposé à suivre
aveuglement gerbe also know il a ainsi
déclaré qu'il ne prendrait aucune
décision brusque sur le déconfinement
tout en précisant que le brésil allait
porter le nombre de tests de 24 à 40,6
millions
l'accent dans tout ce que nous allons
faire est mis sur les personnes nous
pouvons parler de santé d'économie peu
importe
en fin de compte nous parlons des gens
c'est pour cela que nous sommes ici pour
apporter une meilleure vie à la société
et au peuple brésilien malgré son impact
sur l'économie
68% des habitants approuve le
confinement selon un sondage publié le
18 avril au brésil
le coc u19 aurait déjà infecté 40000
personnes et causé la mort de 2500
patients